salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
j'espère que vous allez bien nous ça va
très bien aujourd'hui c'est pas très
sympathique
on a une route assez passant très au
dessus donc ça devrait pas mal on a
aussi un bel endroit avec pas mal de
piétons en fins et des péniches de
l'autre côté déjà été fait mais
néanmoins moi aussi j'ai quelque chose
là on voit que l'eau est assez pollué
c'est à l'âge comme ça a lâché aussi il
ya des kg 1
est ce que ce serait pas le premier
coffre fort lorsque c'est possible
ben au poids c'est possible
ça ce serait magique juste on dit on n'a
jamais fait de coffre il ya les bulles
qui arrive c'était pile au milieu du
pont
peut-être surtout voir si on veut sortir
commencé à tirer vers le haut ouais
c'est pas très lourd au caire
doucement à travailler mon élan c'est
une bombe
quelques noms c'est une bombe soit dans
forget a offert
attends reste comme ça tu peux ouais ben
oui c'est un moteur de bateau ça mais
interview alors une grosse pompe dans
tout cas c'est pas une bombe consentir
épatant du moyen
les cinq centres us à temps
vas-y blocs lovelock bien le voir
progressivement progressivement en même
temps en même temps chez
ban
photo
on retient actuellement
c'est dur
ainsi pour cette merde pas extrêmement
lourd mais c'est lourd
je suis bien ça va
ouais
attention
sur nick
allez c'est bon ça matar fall secure
aussi y en a qui savent exactement ce
que c'est
après nous le rachat sera au point
différents c'est à la base
samba est rempli de base
ah oui là on va te rencontrer ce soir là
voilà
pas mal
donc là il ya mon frère qui a trouvé
quelque chose sa bulle
c'est ce qui est bien c'est que c'était
en plein milieu donc qui va être
intéressant
assez étonnant
a bon espoir
quelque chose de lourd au mieux que ça
peut être
peut-être mais d'une péniche
et
il est là
tu vas pas perdu avec ton est lancé on
pas une manche
des panneaux
ah ouais ouais aux hobbies ça peut s'en
débarrasser en plein milieu
ce qui est fini
un an et dessus
il est beau il est il est quand même pas
mal malgré tout il est pas mal
j'avais bon espoir voilà du coup on est
l'autre côté du pont on a traversé pour
avoir un angle différent tu paries sur
quoi la voyais pas comme le moteur
qu'est ce que c'est
jallow une chaise j'aspire en tenant une
chaise de pêcheurs est allégué elle a
pris pompon or si elle est bonne ou pas
en tout cas faudrait remettre un peu les
soucis oui pour de la m un peul
électrolyse ah ouais mais là il n'ya pas
d'assise à temps mais si peut-être la 6è
les regarde le dossier des trucs et en
bois sylvie de la mousse passé en bois
d'accord pourquoi pas c'est ma deuxième
gré les gouttes à les affaiblir ma
deuxième chez ce nom m à ses côtés dans
l'herbe
ouais j'ai eu un truc
ah c'est un vieux couteau ça ça c'est un
manche de couteau mais il a pris cher il
ya plus de lam dong
dommage c'est peut-être la gamme a6 et
la lame je tente le bout de la lame
il ya toujours le truc là bas je pensais
amusant
oui oui du sang soit un coup de vent il
perd sa chaise il a pas des mains il est
foutu prochain et il a choisi la tournée
alors oui la tournée
c'est très lourd bah c'est un gros tube
un an
le vendeur n'est pas encore peur de
choper temps du mans
je suis passé par dessus toi tu là bas
voilà encore un papa très choquant ça va
ça va ça vient moi aussi j'ai un boulot
oui ah ah c'est pas impossible mais il
est plus gros que l'autre c'est un encan
plus gros tubes moi j'ai envie de
remonter à temps un [ __ ] c'est rempli
de mer c'est rapide merde
olala ont fait glisser comme ça on l'a
mais nous c'est pas profond non
seulement
non pour aller mais beaucoup dit
à
on va mettre dedans
dans ce revers
o la taille des trucs pas le poids
surtout
c'est hyper lourd pas le poids c'est
rempli non et en français ouais bon
tempo
bon là se vider de ses vidéos
les vaches mortes
ah ouais
attendent a dit on fait rouler ont fait
rouler si si si si on le fait rouler en
biais cela dit comme ça oui encore fait
rouler voilà je me suis sorti aussi
débloquer on verra après pour tourner
autour a soulevé va tirer ce bout là non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
justement
je suis fier alors c'est quoi ta pêche
perdre ce briquet un cadeau d'honneur
mais d'une sorte de cure et rigolo à il
est pas mal à regarder ce qui est sortie
du tube une anguille
mais elle était dans le gros tube qu'on
vient de sortir regardez la taille par
rapport à ma main et au cou dans l'eau
je sais pas si ça ça m'a aidé à m'en ont
pas cessé pas électrique en plus
en tout cas elle va vers la belle la
bonne direction voilà tous dans l'eau
[Musique]
incroyable
hop
lb oui l'on sait pas si elle sait si
elle c'est un regarde n'ont peut-être
pas
si on dirait un
attend il faut l'aider 1 tu vas pas du
bon sens ah ouais mais bon voilà parce
qu'on attrape la à l'évasion s'était
découvrez sa mort sans savoir si sa mort
était assez pâle hectic dans les
rivières a pêché wave asie notamment on
va rigoler je vous dis je la pousse
notamment croissance est minuscule
rendra demain glissé aller j'hésite même
pas ça on connais pas enfin régulier
je suis même pas si je vais réussir à
les saisir qu'on va chez pas alors et sa
magie protéger
la lune de sauver c'est déjà ça
incroyable ouais on rate là on va
essayer ce petit peloton qui est temps
que donc la dame sortir une boîte à
outils en bon état et à quels sont donc
ces lourds et un gros truc où là c'est
une grosse game basique
ah d'accord
un bloc en béton trop guère plus rien à
part des branches
voilà les amis cette vidéo de pêche
touche à sa fin donc vous avez vu on a
été attaqué par une anguille on a sorti
une grosse gouttières et plein d'autres
choses
là on vient de tout nettoyer on a tous
amenés à la voiture il nous reste juste
le moteur de bateau a récupéré le
récupérer tout de suite
bon bien sûr on a dû laisser la
gouttière on appellera sûrement la
mairie pour la récupérer et maintenant
c'est le dernier effort de la journée
avant allez c'est parti
avant le réconfort entreprend un bout
non juste le goût juste le bout pour
andy on dirait une enclume toilettes oui
allez on se dit à bientôt pour une
prochaine partie de pêche